hello there December 3rd is the date for
the next Fortnight event that's
1895 days since fortnite Battle Royale
released today we are going to go
through every live event in fortnite
history let's do this you crazy
28 days on the island it was all about
survival but that all changed when a
meteor was spotted overhead once it hit
fortnite officially had a storyline the
visitor was revealed who rushed over to
a mountain lair and the first ever live
event saw a huge rocket Target tilted
Towers before whizzing around and
finally cracking reality above our heads
opening Rifts to other worlds without
any explanation it was soon after that
one of the most beloved inanimate
objects joined the island on day 333 an
unannounced mini live event only seen by
people who were playing the game in that
very moment Kevin had arrived and he
suddenly started moving rolling and
rolling crushing anything in his path
until he reached loot Lake on day 359
the anniversary week of fortnite Battle
Royale Kevin rolled into loot Lake he
melted and the lake became a material
we'd never seen before
soon Kevin returned by lifting the loot
lake house into the air and over that
season that floating house moved around
the island creating runes we wouldn't
understand for chapters and then the
Multiverse was confirmed to us on day
405 during the butterfly event Kevin
took us to a world Between Worlds the
in-between the butterfly bring us back
to the island back to our reality The
Following Season the snow started to
fall and slowly a new character was
revealed floating in a Frozen ball the
Ice King awakened on day 481 he acted
creating a huge astral projection of
himself and covered the island with even
more snow and ice this was the lowest
rated live event ever but thankfully
there were more this season marshmallow
rocked up at Pleasant Park only two
weeks later and revolutionized what a
live event could be banging out Tunes
while we all danced together an amazing
change in Direction there was actually
three Live Events this season with the
first ever New Year's Eve countdown
played every hour in game as 2019 teen
approached it was almost 100 days before
the next live event arrived as a vault
was discovered under loot Lake and we
worked together to open it in here we
chose the future it was only to unvault
a weapon but it gave us a new level of
interaction we'd never had before we
chose the drum gun to make streamers cry
it was epic in here were more story
Clues as a mysterious ball of energy
which would become the center of the
story was seen and a Helm of a character
who would be pivotal to the story The
Following Season the live event
continued with a volcanic explosion that
decimated the island except no sweat
Insurance the only building left
standing in tilted Towers The Following
Season saw a monster revealed inside
polar Peak his eye peering out and
inevitably he escaped Singularity was
prepared for this eventuality and used
the dormant volcano to build a Mech
capable of protecting that ball of
energy we saw last season the battle
took place on day 663 and it was brutal
with the Mech losing an arm luckily a
sword was casually hidden in neo-tilted
Singularity statue was actually the hilt
for this weapon worthy of finishing the
Beast the real issue now was that the
mech decided to crack the zero point
which made all reality unstable
season X arrived and inter-dimensional
travel was confirmed as the scientist
was revealed a member of the seven who
recreated the original meteor event but
paused at the moment before impact
finally on day 748 the plan started the
meteor was transported over to loot Lake
above that destabilized zero point and
seven Rockets helped create the most
talked about event in fortnite history
the island was no more the game was over
Nah The Island rebuilt itself and
chapter 2 began
[Music]
two years after fortnite Battle Royale
was released a brand new island was here
for us to discover we experienced a new
type of live event on day 810 fortnite
was used to advertise other products
with Star Wars the first of many what
was amazing about this live event was
that it directly ties into the movie the
only place to hear the emperor's
monologue was in fortnite the day of the
Sith so does that mean fortnite is canon
in Star Wars oh and of course it's New
Years so the countdown came back Travis
Scott appeared on day 942 as a musical
performance to build on the marshmallow
event this event showed the impact of
fortnite and what this platform could
showcase watching this back now it gives
me goosebumps every time
[Music]
finally another story driven live event
was seen on day 994 one of the most
beloved characters in the game Midas was
secretly creating a Doomsday Machine
under the island and it was time to
switch it on breaking through the
confines of the agency a device capable
of pushing back the storm appeared
somehow we were transported into the
office of IO agent Jones an unknown
agency had been watching us from the
Shadows controlling the island little
did we know how much this Insight would
affect us for years to come chapter 2
Season 4 brought the superheroes of
Marvel's Universe to the island to face
the impending Devourer of Worlds who was
coming over to eat the zero point he
flew closer and closer each update until
day
1177 arrived in one of the greatest Live
Events ever we piloted the battle bus
assisted Iron Man as we tricked the bad
guy into eating millions of those buses
before rifting him back home saving the
zero point you did it thank you bus
driver
oh and of course another New Year's
Event 2021 and Ting the next live event
wasn't actually live it was a single
player mission available for a few days
heavily Story related we saw agent Jones
finally leave the imagined order and
switch allegiance to the seven bringing
their leader the foundation to the
island and giving us more lore about
characters yet to meet Geno and the
sisters the event ended with the
foundation sealing himself into the zero
point to help it heal and Jones was
trapped in the loop destined to lose his
mind or Worse be captured by the i o
chapter 2 Season 7 saw a new foe arrive
the cube Queen and her last reality
followers this Evil Genius used a live
event to gain information a music event
focused around Ariana Grande was
actually a ruse for the queen to scan
our memories to see our weaknesses we
were up against it so we had to partner
with the imagined order even though we
don't trust them Dr Sloan was in charge
of getting us aboard the mothership in
operation Sky fire
1448 days since we started playing
fortnite we planted bombs to take out
the spaceship and saw how cubes were
created as we looked to escape Sloan
showed her real intentions we are
fighting a war in which we are
hopelessly outgunned
leaving us to perish on the mothership
with the bombs we planted ourselves this
led to a moment like no other we touched
one of the dormant cubes and it became
blue switching Allegiance from the
imagined order to us it wanted to
protect us as the ship explodes we
somehow survived and so did the Bromance
because legends never die on the island
a golden Cube was now seen rolling
around and powering other purple cubes
who duplicated at an alarming rate Kevin
the original Cube thought to be inside
steamy Stacks was also freed as the next
live event approached a live event that
would finish the chapter the end was
here day
1531 started with the blue cube
protecting us from the Queen's Onslaught
but we didn't stand a chance luckily the
seven were watching and came to help
rescuing the Loopers before venturing
into the island using the mysterious
bunkers we'd watched for years down here
the foundation was able to free Jonesy
under seven flip to the entire Island
defeating the cube Queen and taking us
to A New Beginning another new chapter
we awoke and spoke to the foundation who
set out the plan to free the zero point
from IO tyranny oh and like usual
another happy New Year event was seen as
the new chapter continued earthquakes
began to be felt underfoot as the io
attacked a full-scale war played out
which led to the imagined order building
another Doomsday Machine but this one
was here to wipe out all of life
permanently no response the collider
event arrived on day
1698 the pulsing Tower needed to be
destroyed to do it we first found a
missing member of the seven the Paradigm
the greatest pilot to ever live and it
so happened that we had to rebuild the
mech from chapter one with a new paint
job we jumped in the Gunner seat and
attacked the i o head-on causing the
collider to fall into a cavern now on
foot we fought alongside the foundation
and Jonesy defeat eating Sloan and her
minions and finally reclaiming the zero
point we had done it the island was
saved and the zero point was no longer
controlled by the imagined order the
event ended with the foundation and
Jones following Geno the iOS commanding
officer into the zero point now the
island is free and the zero point has
fallen dormant on December the 3rd we
find out what is next in our adventure
who will our opponents be the herald has
changed the island into Chrome which
moves closer to the zero point every day
reality will be changed again forever
day one thousand eight hundred and
ninety five is coming I'm Adam you're
awesome I'll see you next time
foreign